Aqua alpha take one.
B6
Umm
Listen, buddy,
You're fired.
I know
you're not too familiar
with the concept of fire
cause you live with
Sebastian the crab
Unda da sea.
Is this your national anthem?
Everythings betta
down where it’s wetta
take it from
meeeee
I contribute
the might of Atlantis
to the team.
What about the power
the power of My Little Pony?
As long as we're bringing in
bullshit stuff.
**Laughing**
What about the power
of Narnia?
and that’s super helpful,
cause Atlantis is a bunch of bullshit.
I'm sorry.
We're from different parts
of the world.
You're a sky guy.
I'm a sea guy.
We're masters
of our own domain.
Didn't mean to interrupt.
Just ran down to Costco
to get a bucket
of your friends.
You recognize
any of these motherf***ers?
Yeah.
That's Steve.
I hope he died
with honor.
Gonna be honest,
I wasn't expecting a yes here.
Of all the fish
that I could have
bought
to make fun of you,
I bought one named Steve?
No that’s Steve.
Kay.
You went to Costco
just to make fun of me?
I didn't.
Alfred did.
He doesn't have much to do
with his afternoons.
It's pretty much.
Wake up.
Give me a little.
Woo hoo!!
**Laughter**
With the mighty
trident of Neptune.
Looks like the
swizzle stick
you put in an oyster shooter.
That looks like
John Goodman's fork.
Here's a couple tridents fo ya
Poland Springs.
Tri trident.
Three.
Harvey Dent.
Can we trust him?
Sorry,
I got sidetracked.
I'm so sorry.
I've been trying to be
culturally polite
and ignore it,
but you smell like
Nagiri,
left inside of Nori,
left inside
of a van, left
in the desert of New Mexico
for three nights,
and no ventilation.
You smell like a bait
shop down by the bayou
in January
Wait, that's not a hot month.
Thank you.
Saltiest Joe Rogan fan.
You look like you work
in a crystal shop.
You can be the stand in
for Zack Galifianakis
if he ever frosts
his tips.
Eat sh*t.
**Laughing**
Your d*ck has scales?
Scaled for her pleasure.
I'm sorry,
but even for me,
that's over the line.
**Laughing**
I'm going to stop you
right there Evian.
This is just
for office use only.
That was perfect.
I can breathe underwater.
So you can,
you know, be alive
while you're speaking to fish?
Night vision.
To see the fish
before you talk to him.
Nobody wants to be an idiot
floating around
in a dark ocean,
talking
only to widen and reveal
there's no fish listening.
That would be embarrassing.
A guy talking underwater
is only embarrassing
if there's not a fish hear.
Are you getting this?
In an ideal world,
could fire yourself
Long John Dipsh*t.
Who is your nemesis?
The Gordon's fisherman.
Do you not trust him?
Do you not trust
the Gordon's fisherman
because he killed
so many of your ex-lovers?
Go 69, a seahorse,
you f**kin pervert.
**Laughing**
We're definitely gonna
to use that.
Well, I quit.
Sorry to lose ya Red Lobster.
I'll miss
your unlimited breadsticks.
Go form a Creed
cover band.
Even if you don't have
a jellyfish stuck to ya
I'd love to take a leak all over you.
**Laughing**